Here's why I think this is a parable
based on an actual occurrence.
That this is not simply hypothetical.
It's referring to an actual
occurrence where the tax collector and
the Pharisee went up. Why? Can you
explain to me? Is it a coincidence that
in the next chapter now remember when
the man prayed God be propitious to me
forgive me by atoning for me
he doesn't know if God answered him
right Jesus is telling you this man's
prayer was answered but he doesn't know
that he went down to his house right
notice he went up and he went down
correct where
get ready to be blown away if you forgot
gotten when I did a session on this
creatures of repetition.
Here's where you're going to get blown
away. Okay, you ready?
Watch. Did the man know? Did God tell
the man he had been justified? No. Jesus
is telling you.
All right. So, the man prayed. Jesus
said he was justified.
Tell me if this is a coincidence. Luke
19:1-10. He entered and was passing
through Jericho. There was a man named
Zakius. He was a chief tax collector and
he was rich. Coincidence? He was trying
to see who Jesus was. Couldn't because
of the crowd, because he was short. He
ran on ahead. Now, I'm going to show you
now the words in Greek how they're all
connected. If you had the Greek, you're
going to see the connection. climbed up
into a sycamore tree to see him, for
he's going to pass that that way. Notice
he climbed up. I'm going to show you. It
comes from the same root word. He went
up to see Jesus.
Two men went up into the temple.
Went up.
He went up to see Jesus. He went up a
tree to see Jesus.
The tax collector Pharisee went up to
the temple to meet with God.
Let's see who's going to catch this. Or
are you going to go to sleep and say,
"Oh, come on." And the Pharisee
represents the people who look down on
tax collectors because they think
they're better than these sinners.
Watch here.
When Jesus came to the place, he looked
up and saw him and said to him, "Zakius,
hurry and come down, for today I must
stay at your house."
The man went down to his house justify.
Why? Because the justifier of men, the
one who makes propitiation,
heard his prayer and came to his house
to justify him.
Let it sink in before I move on.
Did it sink in?
Now he knows God justified him. Now he
knows God accepted his repentance. But
now notice genuine true repentance means
a conviction in your heart that you did
something wrong.
You change your mind about it and then
you do something about it.
You turn away from that sin. That's true
repentance, right? So he went down to
his house justified.
Who then came to his house? Who came
down
to his house
with Jesus?
The tax collector Zakius.
What was the context of this parable? He
also spoke this parable to certain
people who are convinced of their own
righteous who despise all others.
Pharisee representing those who think
they're better than sinners. Watch the
context here.
Okay. When they saw it, they all
murmured saying, "He has gone into lodge
with a man who's a sinner." Are you
still not making the connection? Here
are the people
that Jesus says here
are convinced they are self-righteous
and better than others. Connection?
No. Yes. You making connection?
Is it a parable or is it about him
Zakius
that when he prayed in the temple Jesus
came to say your prayer has been
answered I have come to justify you
so not making any connection why I say
this parable may not just be an
illustration but maybe referring to
actual situation of two individuals
okay
Zakius stood and said to the Lord behold
Lord half of my goods I give to the
poor. See, I have repented. I was wrong
and I will make amends. That's
repentance.
Not just name it, claim it, buddy. If I
have wrong wrongfully exacted anything
of anyone, I restore four times as much.
Jesus said to him, "Today salvation has
come to this house." Why? Because Jesus
is Jehovah. Who is salvation? Because he
also is a son of man. For the son of
man, I'm sorry, also is the son of
Abraham. For the son of man came to seek
and to save that which was lost. What am
I showing you here? I'm connecting this
with Jesus because Jesus is the God who
justified the tax collector who
justifies all tax collectors because
he's the God who made propitiation.
remember that word.
Now, if I show you the words, how
they're related, going up and all that,
it's it's it's obviously the case. I can
show you if you want if you want to take
a few more minutes.
Going up, coming down. It's it's a you
can do it yourself. Well, let me just
see because it's going to take a little
longer than normal, but nonetheless,
let's go here. Let me just show you what
I can do.
See, it's going to
nonetheless.
And then one second so you can see
Luke 19. We're going to compare contrast
and compare. All right. Luke 19. Let's
look at here. All right. Let's see here.
Was passing through. Behold, a man by
name called Zakius. He was a chief tax
law. Rich was seeking to and he was
seeking to see Jesus. Right. So the tax
collector went up seeking God when he
went up to the temple. Okay. Here he's
seeking Jesus.
All right. So what did he do? Small.
Notice he who humbles himself lowers
himself.
Lowers himself humbles himself. Are you
seeing how it's connecting? Small.
Whoever humbles himself not stands up.
Making a connection. small
running to the front. He went up a nei.
Now, let's go here. Let's see if there's
any connections.
Oh, come on. All right. Let's see if
there's any connections.
He now spoke trusting themselves that
they are righteous despising the others.
A parable. All right. went up anisan
went up.
Same word. You see it?
See it?
He went up to the sycamore tree. They
went up anisan.
So you don't think I'm lying. I'm not
making stuff up. up. I told you in
English is playing it up. But when you
look at a Greek, I mean, these Greek
readers have Oh, wow. to pray.
The one a Pharisee, the other a tax
collector.
All right. Anyway, to himself was
praying.
All right.
I'm not like that tax collector. O
tonas.
Yeah. Blah blah blah blah. But the tax
collector a far off standing
or
trying to say how you Greek speakers say
would not lift up his eyes. He lowered
himself. Right? Notice he's lowering
himself. He's not looking up. He would
lift up his eyes. Means he's lowering
himself. And Zakius was a man of small
stature. Be merciful.
Make propitiation to me.
went down.
Kibi went down to the house of him
rather than that for everyone exalting,
right? Exaling. If you exalt, you'll be
humbled.
Humble. But if you humble yourself,
you'll be exalted. So notice he was
small stature.
This is connecting it with humbling
yourself, making yourself small in the
eyes of God. Went down, right? Okay. Are
you seeing it? Oh, sorry. Let me go back
here. Let me make his Let me see if more
connection. So, it's clear. It is clear.
These two are connected. And you're
supposed to see Jesus is the God that
the tax collector went up to meet.
Jesus is the God that the tax collector
prayed to asking God to be propitious to
him to forgive him. And Jesus heard
because he went down to his house.
That's the connection you're supposed to
make.
Understand?
Went up
to see who?
Him? Jesus. Right? What did they do?
They went up to the temple to see God.
to meet God there, right? Sorry, let me
find it. I hope you guys are okay.
You're not bored with all this, right?
I'm going this time so you can see it.
They went up to see God in the temple
cuz God lives there.
Went up. He went up to do what? He went
up to see Jesus
on EI.
Are you making the connection?
Lord Jesus Christ reigns.
Jesus said to him, Zakius, come down.
Same word.
Katabi.
Come down to your house.
All right,
let's go here.
Kibi,
come down Zakius to your house. Tax went
down to his house justified.
Demos.
Sink it in.
You say always awesome here, brother.
You s you sinking in.
He came down
where justified
right to his house. What did Jesus say
to him?
beat come down to your house cuz I'm the
God who has come to justify you and save
you. He came down
and remember they said he's dining with
a sinful man. What did he say? Remember
go he's a sinful man.
Be merciful to me the sinner
to
Yes, he is a sinful man. That's who
Jesus came. He came for the sinful ones.
See, it's even the same word.
I mean, I'm I'm just going slow, so
let's sink in.
He is the God.
And who justified him? Who saved him?
Who was propitious to him? Jesus says it
right here. Today salvation so
came to his house. But who came to his
house? Salvation in the flesh because
Jesus name means Jehovah salvation. So
literally salvation entered his house as
a man in the flesh with a physical body
because he is Yahushua Jehovah of
salvation the son of man who came to
seek and to save
those having been lost.
Did we make the case here?